[موسيقى]
أردت أن أفعل شيئًا
يريد الناس فيه الانخراط في شيء
كان نشاطًا في المنزل ، لكنني
اعتقدت أنني قد أنشأت مجموعة ستؤدي
على مدار خمسة أيام في رحلة المخيم الأساسي التي
تجذب الكثير من  يعرف الأشخاص أنه من
الممكن الوصول إليه من الارتفاع الموجود فيه إلى حد ما
حيث يمكنك القيام بالارتفاع الذي
يجب عليك القيام به كل يوم أو وجبة الإفطار إذا
استيقظت مبكرًا بما يكفي ،
قمت بتكوين مجموعة من خلال الشك على
Instagram وسألك عما إذا كان أي شخص يريد
الانضمام  أجابني في 30 شخصًا
وأرادوا المشاركة وكلنا كل
يوم فيديا الارتفاع الذي يجب أن
نفعله على سلالمنا أو سلالمنا ، بعض
الناس لديهم خطوة واحدة فقط ، لذا
فهم يقومون بالكثير من الخطوات في خطوة واحدة فقط
شعرت حقًا أنني بحاجة إلى القيام
بشيء ما ، وبعد يومين
، أعيش في منزل طويل جدًا في والتون
وأخذت كوبًا من الشاي لزوجتي في
السرير وقلت من خلال عمليات
الإغلاق الكبيرة ، لكن لدينا  لأشعر
وكأنني تسلقت قمة إيفرست
وفجئت الفكرتان  لقد استيقظت [الموسيقى] صباح يوم الثلاثاء صباحًا مفكرًا أن ذلك قد يكون
طريقة جيدة لجمع الأموال لزيادة
الوعي بما هو مهم حقًا.
ما فاجأني حقًا
هو أنني تمكنت
من زيادة السرعة وكان اليوم الأول هو الإصدار 8 من الطلاء الخاص بنا
ولم أحقق هدفي تمامًا وهو تسلق 25٪
ولكن بصرف النظر عن ذلك ، نعم
الجانب العقلي من ذلك  نفس
الدرج مرارًا وتكرارًا 350
مرة في اليوم والذي أحضرني حقًا إلى
هنا
[موسيقى]
داخل المجموعة التي كان لدينا أشخاص
حصلوا على إجازة فقدوا وظائفهم ولكن أيضًا
العمال الرئيسيين وكذلك الأشخاص الذين يعملون
من المنزل والذين يعانون من كليهما
إن وجود شيء نركز فيه على
إعطاء أنفسنا عن قصد ووجود
فريق يدعمنا من خلال هذا أعتقد أنه من
المهم جدًا
[موسيقى]
أفكر في السباحة في القناة
في حوض الاستحمام الخاص بي حتى أنني لست كافيًا للقيام بذلك
[موسيقى]